you dummy I just told you the only
reason you think you're in love with me
is because your ex-wife hired me to put
a potion in your dudy mug to make you
fall in love with her again long enough
to trick you into signing your computer
company over to her but it backfired and
you fell in love with me instead I'm a
goddamned witch Craig and there's
nothing between you and me we're just
potion Pals will you just give me a
chance to show you that I'm the man you
should be with and how are you going to
do that I'm going to brew a potion just
as strong as yours and I'm going to put
it in your dudy mug and you're going to
fall in love with me just as hard as I
fell in love with you what about your
ex-wife I killed her right before you
got
here holy [__] come on give me some
potion just a drop of potion I just want
a little bit of potion potion potion
potion pretty pleased potion is as
potion
does